okay everyone captain marvel this week
has released some new set photos of brie
Larson in costume as Carol Danvers and
despite the familiar red and blue with
the gold star costume Captain Marvel is
known from known for from the comics
this costume has a green color tone oh
my gosh now it could be that this
version of the costume is meant to look
like the original Captain Marvel marvel
as a Kree warrior who will be played by
Jude Law in the movie whose Kree
military uniform was green colored in
the comics marvel's alter-ego dr. walter
lawson meets carol danvers eventually
passes on the mantle of Captain Marvel
to her the history of this character's
very long and very interesting a little
complicated and also you're seeing the
comic book or origin they specifically
said they're gonna change it for her so
that she becomes like not attached to
another they're gonna expedite it and
convince it so maybe what we're saying
here is Danvers in this green colored
costume as a throwback to that Kree
military uniform look the original
Captain Marvel wore and this maybe this
is just like her first look in the movie
before she like changes into her classic
look by the end of the movie kind of way
like Tony Stark and the first Iron Man
had that weird goofy clunky suit and
then eventually got the more refined
look Marvel does a really good job with
that because it's uh it's fun to throw
like a nod to the history of the
character you got the mark 1 it was cool
because I read Ben rewatching the Marvel
movies for the series we do on this
channel but re watching that it's like
it's kind of fun not because it's like
we're I don't know paying some respects
I had another point in there told me
forgot what it was and I know other
characters have done that too like you
guys do like for Captain America when he
was doing the propaganda stuff in the
first Avengers movie which is really fun
you got the grey Hulk in multiple
versions of the Hulk depending on how
they decide to change what his face
looks like exactly these nods to the
different origin and I feel like you're
gonna get the helmet too because he
usually has like this like skin-tight
helmet with a little little mohawk
you probably ain't get that was the Iron
Fist one where you like goes through
[Music]
so you're thinking that this is a nod to
the original suit and not like this is
Jude Law's costume and then she happens
to fit in it perfectly
yeah it's cama when she's in the forest
no that's true Ella can change you stand
out like a sore thumb not so fast on the
color of it and like the wise I'm
talking I want to talk about the quality
of this costume because it's real bad
that is not her real hair is it that has
got to be a wig no way it's really like
we're talking about the cartoon it all
looks fake to me
the costume in itself does it looks like
she's rocking up to comic-con what
here's a cosplay a good way to point out
how much talking about note the elbow it
like doesn't Bend well with her looks
like it's 2 inches too long for her the
suit as well because it bunches all the
way down the legs I think they would
then would definitely agree that this is
a proto suit and early stage the other
one I think I like your idea I also
think it could be a pension nod to her
origin it could be like a flight suit
guys this junk room we didn't look we
didn't look properly but look look what
you're not supposed to there's junk room
oh wow yeah we don't know how Kree
biology works right they could have seen
every single other female tailored
costume ever has there ever been that
much room there ever before does she
keep the gun yeah you don't know what do
you keep yours
[Laughter]
this is not make me excited about the
movie and I want to ask you guys did
this make you more or less inclined to
watch it be excited for it like I want
money already talk about a podcast so go
see anyways I wish I've got to see
Suicide Squad - as well I think every
pre trailer set photo that I've ever
seen pretty moving they need to be like
what that's lame like listen the one
that always sticks out to me is in well
there's
dr. strange where it's like them running
down like a street and they do that
goofy jump and then just like land after
like six inches of a shocker for
spider-man homecoming it was like it was
a shocking yeah or win Benedict
Cumberbatch played Smaug and there's a
it's wearing that goofy suit with the
ping pong balls on it's like oh wow wow
I was like they need to come back with a
great actor Emily yeah I should've seen
this because now I won't be able to
unsee it when I watch the movie I think
once Eric and I played something like 20
questions or something I guess the thing
we had to guess was Benedict Cumberbatch
as smog in the BTS footage where he's
doing the weird job I was a repulsor
though for me you know it wasn't that
bad I enjoyed it
she pulled teeth out of people's heads
and made a spear out of it right it is
not into something cooler at the end but
well let us know what you guys think
about this green costume and this
interestingly design costume in the
comments down below tweet us at new
rocks eyes and of course subscribe to
this channel for more coverage of all
the upcoming Marvel movies thanks
everybody